that's not the plan
why isn't actually Jaden like you some
listen there is a certain aspect of the
internet that rides hard for Christian
and automatically oh yeah so I don't
really care yeah it's like a pick a side
thing so pick a side then so my
thumbs up I mean like pick a side I
don't give a [__] because to me I'm not
in a competition I'm in my own thing no
traffic there ain't no traffic if you're
in your own lane you feel me so it's
kind of like I don't give a [__] so if
that's if you want to side with that
side with that because you already know
my [__] play in the club we going up
well I'm just curious like
I'm sure people like like you said like
we've seen memes about the Drewsky thing
and it's funny that's great well I think
it's something that you take it that way
because I think
we are in an aspect where everyone's
gonna come at you on the internet yeah
regardless I mean at first obviously it
was kind of like I said how do you deal
with it is it hard at first it was kind
of like it was like what do you mean
like um student this I'm that like ew
right but I think that I don't I don't
like come on now the thing is is like I
think with anything especially like
internet driven because again this guy's
a goat on the internet he is so much so
okay can we shut your guy's door who
sounds like he's in there having a
podcast shut the [__] up
we recorded tiny
shut the [__] up
she sounds like he's in there cussing
someone sound like you having a podcast
[__]
no I was gonna say though like listen
like bullying is real like self-esteem
is a real thing like you know okay so
the social media thing is a real thing
because I got a taste of it when I was
pregnant so it was kind of like this
[__] sucked for sure I can only imagine
because I really saw some [__] I did not
want to see when I was pregnant like the
whole time not like start to finish like
oh
you should it's just you don't [__] you
don't forget like because yeah the
internet will forget but it's you
personally will never ever ever like get
off you right like even if you if that
one person bring it up oh I'm gonna suck
you in your mouth my thing is is like we
all take in comments a certain way but
no matter what they might
I watch him so I kind of like okay so
like because there's plenty of things
they say about him and it's like oh
that's so cap like it's so kept to like
where's the point I'm like okay now I
know the internet is ridiculous are you
getting like um
hate DMs like crazy people saying hey
I've had like six Instagrams all her
Instagram every single one they delete
them they just flag you yep why the
[__]
I don't even know I've made like six in
the last month
Rock Hive coming for you yeah
I think it's her personally but I think
no no it's her fans it's just a pickup
she has a very heart like she has like
we did that interview I saw it and that
just kind of gives like what type of
females was out there like yeah so
you're on that that's probably why you
don't like it and me personally like if
I don't agree with what you doing or how
you doing it I'm not going like hype you
up I'm gonna be the first to be like nah
you know
so that's why me and her kind of like
fell out like I don't agree with a lot
of things so it's like I can't co-sign
it came out for it you at the club
pregnant eight months like falling off
it's just like bro I can't how can I
defense that like Baby yeah I don't care
how much money they paying you it's not
worth it's not worth it yeah make the
money don't let it make you like I don't
care how much somebody pays me I
couldn't do nothing
homosexually feel me
how much how much of a 10 billion
dollars nothing bro if they gave me a
billion said hey yo kiss bootleg camera
[__] you wait a billion dollars I
wouldn't kiss you that's crazy I'm
kissing you for a billion that's what
I'm saying it's like for a billion
dollars I'll kiss blue so this is yeah
that's the difference for a billion
dollars
principal [__] the principal it's 2023
give me my bill I don't know maybe
because I don't know I mean
I never hear from me again I understand
both sides I understand both sides I'll
never knock the hustle for me I've never
poke a shamrock on any type of contract
pause this one bro I've never put
Cristiano any type of contract any type
of paperwork I'm like it's not about
that I could have I could have had her
sign
her whole life away but that I don't
want that you know I don't want your
life